[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tortenwelt heute gibt's wieder ein
kleines Rezept für Halloween aber wer
kein Halloween feiert oder keine Party
schmeißt kann das auch einfach so backen
die Kekse die ich nämlich heute Backe
sehen total süß aus und schmecken auch
sehr gut es sind nämlich
erdnussbutterkekse und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal die Zutaten wir
brauchen 100 15 g Butter 130 g Zucker
200 g Mehl ein Ei einen Teelöffel
Backpulver eine gute prisese Salz ich
habe jetzt hier noch etwas Vanilleschote
wenn ihr das nicht habt könnt auch
Vanillezucker nehmen oder es auch
weglassen und hier habe ich noch 170 g
Erdnussbutter das sind die Zutaten für
den Teig und hier habe ich auch schon
die Zutaten für die Dekoration und zwar
brauchen wir Pralinen Runde Pralinen am
besten mit einem Durchm Messer von etwa
2 cm ich habe jetzt hier die Lindor von
lind oder aber auch mal die rocherkugel
hier hingelegt das wird dann der
Spinnenkörper und wir brauchen etwas
kurvertü das ist jetzt
zartbitterkvertüre und hier habe ich
noch etwas weiße Blütenpaste ausgerollt
die steht jetzt hier auch schon ein
bisschen und ist etwas trocken und einen
lebensmittelfarbstift in schwarz zuerst
verrühre ich jetzt die Butter mit dem
Zucker das lass ich jetzt etwa eine
Minute rühren bis die Masse schön ig ist
dann kommt das Ei mit dazu und wird
untergerührt danach gebe ich die
Erdnussbutter mit rein und lass sie ganz
schön geschmeidig rühren und zum Schluss
kommen noch die trockenen Zutaten rein
und werden kurz mit
reingerührt es entsteht dann ein schöner
weicher Teig wie man hier sehen kann die
Zutaten waren ja auch alle zimmerwarm
und jetzt wird der Teig portioniert
normalerweise stellt man ja so ein
Keksteig erst kalt damit er beim Backen
nicht verläuft aber wir wollen heute
dass er verläuft deswegen verwenden wir
ihn so Zimmer wararm ich nehme jetzt ein
Eisportionierer da kann ich nämlich
immer die perfekte Menge ab nehmen und
bemähle jetzt meine Hände
leicht und geb die Kugel da drauf und
Form es einfach noch mal schön zu einer
Kugel muss nicht perfekt sein
und setze auf mein
Backblech und wenn ihr die jetzt da
drauf setzt müsst ihr drauf achten genug
Platz zwischend drin zu
lassen so weil die jetzt noch beim
Backen auseinander
gehen so sehen jetzt die fertigen Kugeln
aus bei mir sind es glaube ich 20 Stück
geworden und die werden jetzt bei 180°
Ober und Unterhitze für 16 Minuten
gebacken nach 10 Minuten nehme ich mir
hier diesen ausrollstab ihr könnt auch
irgendwas anderes nehmen und drück dann
hier den Teig ein damit ich später diese
pralene reinsetzen kann und die Spinne
drin sitzt aber das zeige ich euch
gleich und schieb die jetzt erstmal für
10 Minuten in den
Ofen die Zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um
die Augen der Spinne vorzubereiten und
hier habe ich wie gesagt dieses Stück
Blütenpaste bereits ausgerollt und es
ist ein bisschen angetrocknet und mit
einer Lochtülle werde ich jetzt Augen
ausstechen falls ihr so eine Lochtülle
oder Blütenpaste nicht habt könt ihr z.B
auch Schokolade nehmen also weiße
Schokolade und die dann eben auf die
Pralinen drauf
spritzen und dann könnt ihr einen
lebensmittelstift nehmen und die Augen
einfach drauf malen
[Musik]
entweder so wie hier nach außen dann
können i sie nämlich so schielen
zusammensetzen oder eben so nach außen
oder ihr setzt sie in die Mitte ich find
jetzt so mit dem schielen am besten und
mal deswegen jetzt alle Punkte drauf so
sehen die Kekse jetzt nach dem Backen
aus ich habe sie jetzt noch mal mit dem
Stäbchen nachgedrückt und lass sie jetzt
kurz abkühlen und hier habe ich schon
mal meine kuouvertüre fein gehackt und
geb sie in eine kleine Tüte das könnt
man jetzt auch mit einem Spritzbeutel
machen mit so einem einwegspritzbeutel
aber so eine Gefriertüte hat ja jetzt
jeder daheim da mache ich jetzt ein
Knoten rein erstmal die Luft raus da
kann man auch ein Gummi rein drum herum
wickeln und so lege ich das jetzt hier
in ein Schälchen mit heißem Wasser und
lasse es einfach
schmelzen so hat man die wenigste Arbeit
und die Kekse lasse ich auch ganz kurz
abkühlen und sobald die Kekse lauwarm
sind geht's gleich wieder weiter und
dann könnt ihr euch einfach so eine
Praline nehmen und die da reinsetzen und
mit der Restwärme sollte dann die
Praline so ein bisschen schmelzen und
klebt dann später einfach an dem Keks
fest falls ihr das verpasst habt und der
Keks schon ausgekühlt ist dann könnt ihr
auch einfach die Schokolade nehmen und
das ein bisschen
reinkleben und dann nehme ich mir meine
Schokolade und schneid da jetzt eine
ganz kleine Spitze
ab und damit könnt ihr jetzt noch acht
Beine
anzeichnen zu
[Musik]
klein mal die Luft
rauslassen
[Musik]
und das muss da jetzt alles nicht so
perfekt sein sondern es reicht einfach
wenn sie von innen nach außen gehen und
dann könnt ihr mit der Schokolade auch
noch die Augen aufkleben einfach
bisschen Schokolade
dran und die Augen
[Musik]
andrücken und so sehen dann die fertigen
Kekse aus ich habe die Kekse jetzt schon
probiert und die sind nicht sehr süß
aber weil er da oben eine Schokolade
drauf sitzt finde ich passt es so falls
ihr aber gerne erdnusskekse haben
möchtet die etwas süßer sind gibt
einfach noch ein bisschen Zucker mit
dazu ich lass die jetzt komplett
abkühlen und werde sie dann
wahrscheinlich verschenken so viel Kekse
kann ich nämlich nicht alleine essen und
das Rezept gibt's zum Nachlesen auf
sellis-blog.de und ich freue mich auf
eure Fotos falls ihr diese Kekse auch
nachmacht die sehen nämlich wirklich
super süß aus und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Mal wieder беpт
tchüс